Друзі, всім привіт!
Сьогодні щось трохи шкутильгаю, прихопило коліно.
Настав час звернутися до лікаря
і показати вам зсередини, як функціонує система
охорони здоров'я у Німеччині.
Перший крок – до сімейного лікаря.
Сімейний лікар у цій приватній клініці є водночас і її  власником,  і керівником,
у нього в підпорядкуванні інші лікарі, і підприємцем,
бо від кількості пацієнтів залежить його прибуток.
А відкрив доктор Масуді цю приватну клініку
на першому поверсі власного будинку в Бонні.
На другому - він мешкає з родиною.
За перших ознак хвороби в Німеччині спочатку
звертаються саме до так званого "сімейного лікаря".
Тому приймальні сімейних лікарів часто переповнені.
Мені щастить потрапити на прийом поза чергою,
коли години прийому вже завершені.
Сімейний лікар має визначити, яке лікування мені необхідне.
Щонайменше 45 відсотків усіх німецьких лікарів
працюють у приватних лікарських кабінетах або
приватних клініках - їх називають «Праксіс».
Звідси пацієнт може отримати направлення
на подальше обстеження спеціалістами
або до лікарні швидкої допомоги
чи до клініки на стаціонарне лікування.
Ця картка з мікрочіпом - перепустка до німецької медицини.
Пацієнту необхідно мати картку обов'язкового  медичного страхування,
яка покриває доволі широкий спектр послуг.
Страховий внесок у Німеччині – це 15% від заробітку.
Цю виплату  працівник і роботодавець ділять навпіл.
Гроші накопичуються у державних або приватних
лікарських касах, які і оплачують лікування.
На мою картку застрахована вся родина.
Страховка покриває амбулаторне і стаціонарне лікування.
Виняток - стоматологія і пластична хірургія.
Доктор Масуді з гордістю демонструє устаткування клініки.
Тут у нас діагностична кімната, де можна
провести ультразвукове обстеження.
А це наша маленька лабораторія для аналізів.
Після огляду коліна лікар вирішує, що потужностей
його клініки загальної медицини не вистачить для
повноцінної діагностики і лікування мого випадку.
Для цього я хочу направити вас до лікаря-спеціаліста,
ортопеда, і на МРТ-обстеження.
Прямую до сусіднього району Бонна – Бад Годесберга.
Обов'язкове медичне страхування повністю
покриває і МРТ-обстеження.
Прийом веде доктор Пауль.
Вона є співвласницею цієї приватної клініки.
Разом з нею йдемо до томографа.
Ця спеціальна котушка дає можливість обстежити
коліно у розігнутому положенні.
Обстеження триватиме 20 хвилин.
До речі, коштує такий томограф мільйон двісті  тисяч євро,
задовольняє мою цікавість доктор Пауль.
В руку мені вкладають тривожну кнопку, на голові -  навушники,
бо під час обстеження томограф
видає досить голосні звуки,
які мені особисто нагадують техно у берлінських  клубах.
Після завершення обстеження – висновок лікарки.
Через спеціальну систему, так звану мишку для
запису голосу, я надиктовую результати обстеження.
Голосовий запис одразу перетворюється на текст.
Вердикт такий - у задній частині коліна зібралася рідина.
Отримую компакт-диск із тривимірним записом
мого магнітно-резонансного обстеження
і конверт із роздрукованим висновком.
Далі мій шлях – на фінальну консультацію
до лікаря вузької спеціалізації.
З направленням до ортопеда від мого сімейного лікаря,
далі я сам можу вибрати клініку і фахівця.
Щоправда, іноді обирати доводиться не найкращого
спеціаліста, а того, потрапити до якого можна найшвидше.
Подекуди прийом призначають лише через кілька
місяців, і хвороба до того часу навіть минає.
У гіршому випадку - загострюється.
Домовляюсь про прийом у клініці Йоганнітер - українською Іоанніти -
це назва лицарського ордену, заснованого ще в 11 столітті.
На лікарні красується мальтійський хрест - символ ордену,
який нині діє як благодійна організація.
Невелика частина фінансування цієї лікарні - благодійні внески .
Основна частина - надходження від  страхових внесків лікарських кас.
Тут велике ортопедичне і хірургічне відділення.
Як і в усіх  попередніх клініках, в першу чергу
зчитують дані зі страхової картки.
Медсестра запитує про інтенсивність болю в коліні
за шкалою від нуля до десяти і заносить дані в систему.
Мій сектор номер чотири у зоні із зеленим
смайликом, категорія – легкий біль.
Далі - кімната очікування.
На підході до кабінету ортопеда на стіні медалі
і фото волейбольних команд.
Виявляється, тут центр лікування спортивних травм волейболістів.
Мене зустрічає завідувач ортопедичним
відділенням доктор Віннесберг.
Він вже ознайомився з даними МРТ
і пропонує провести заключний огляд
і діагностичні тести коліна.
Тут не болить. А отут ззовні? – Теж ні.
Це так звані больові точки. – Ні. – Добре.
Тепер повністю випрямте і трохи підніміть.
Гаразд, розслабте. Тепер я потягну коліно вперед.
Тут невеличка кіста Бейкера. Відчутна.
Доктор Віннесберг заспокоює.
Мій випадок лікується фізіотерапією.
Якби ж знадобилася операція, її теж покриває страховка.
Ну що ж, гарні новини від доктора Віннесберга.
Мені не знадобиться ні отаке золоте,
ні отаке срібне коліно.
За його словами, оперативне втручання не потрібне.
За два з половиною роки у Німеччині - це мій
перший досвід такого докладного знайомства
з медичним страхуванням.
Для мене досі незвичний той факт, що ти навіть
не замислюєшся і не знаєш, скільки коштує
та чи інша послуга, а лише простягаєш
картку страхування на стійці реєстрації.
99% населення тут мають медичне страхування, тож
Німеччина в цьому – світовий лідер.
Німеччина, мабуть, має найповнішу та найбільш
ефективну систему медичного страхування у світі.
Дітям до 18 років страховка покриває абсолютно всі випадки.
Малозабезпечені і ті, хто втратив роботу, теж застраховані.
Виклик швидкої і всі оперативні дії реаніматорів
та використані ними ліки теж оплачує страхова компанія.
Однак в Німеччині швидку викликають лише у разі
катастроф, інсультів та інфарктів.
Висока температура, наприклад, не є приводом
виклику рятувальної служби - так тут називають швидку.
Всім бажаю міцного здоров'я і з нетерпінням чекаю
на коментарі та ваші побажання
щодо наступних тем про Німеччину.